[Music]
you
[Music]
the universal unity into which the
living immediate unity of individuality
and substance withdraws is the solace
community which is cease to be the
substance itself unconscious of
individuals and in which they now have
the value of cells and substances
possessing a separate being for self the
universal being the split up into a mere
multiplicity of individuals this
lifeless spirit is inequality in which
all count the same that is as persons
what in the world of the ethical order
was called the hidden divine law has in
fact emerge from its inward state into
actuality in the former state the
individual was actual encountered as
such merely as a blood relation of the
family and this particular individual he
was the departed spirit devoid of a self
now however he has emerged from his
unreal existence because the ethical
substance is only the true spirit the
end of the jewel therefore withdraws
into the certainty of his own self he is
that substance as the positive universal
but his actuality consistent as being a
negative Universal self we saw the
powers and shapes of the epical world
swallowed up in the simple necessity of
a blank destiny this power of the
ethical world is the substance reflected
into its simple unitary nature but that
being which is reflected back into
itself that very necessity of blank
destiny is nothing else but the AI of
self-consciousness
in paragraph
477 we now enter a new subsection of the
first portion of spirit part of the
phenomenology and Hegel titled this in
German Rex Oost on Miller's translating
it as legal status which makes perfect
sense
sue-shaun can be you know condition
status works just as well I think the
person is being understood in terms of a
kind of legality or a kind of justice
Hegel is here going to talk about it in
terms of equality org like height right
things being equal and what's really key
here is that as he's pointed out as he's
talking about in this paragraph the
human law and the divine law that
occupied so much of the space and the
development in the previous two
subsections have now been submerged in
as you said a sort of blind destiny and
the question is well what is what does
that look like and what does that leave
us with so he tells us he talks here
about a universal unity into which the
living immediate unity of individuality
and substance withdraws right so what
what is that that is the ethical
substance that we've been looking for
this entire time and thinking that we we
had our you know finally had grasped it
entirely we wrapped our heads and hearts
and minds around it and it always turned
out to be not complete so what shape of
ethical substance do we have here he
says it's the soulless community and
it's ceased to be the substance so
something else is going to become the
substance in this dialectic that is
unfolding for us well what is it going
to be well a community is composed of
members and in this case what Hegel is
going to focus on is not the family but
rather the individuals individual person
as he's going to tell us so he says
individuals now have the value of self
and substances possessing a separate
being for self what is he talking about
here a kind of individualism not
necessarily exactly what we picture in
our late modern age when we we hear that
term individualism but something that is
related to it something that is on the
way to it this is this is what
communities when they no longer have
sort of a dynamic ideal motivating them
when people are no longer engaging with
each other and they're willing to sort
of put it in the hands of whatever the
law the government in terms of just
rights and legally defined obligations
limits equality's inequalities
procedures all those sorts of things
when they abstract away from what makes
a community distinct what gives it as he
says the soul when that is missing then
the best thing that we do we have is
what what Hegel is calling legal status
right because that's better than sheer
Anarchy or just you know one person
dominating everything although we're
going to see that's going to come about
a little bit later in in this section
this is actually an advance of sorts but
it feels like a loss at this stage so he
tells us the universal being is split up
into a mere multiplicity of individuals
and he talks about here a lifeless
spirit which is really a contradiction
in terms
within the Hegelian system there is no
lifeless spirit a lifeless mind a
lifeless mentality we might say is in
any is an equality in which all count
the same and he says that is as persons
and you understand in this section as
you read a little bit later on that
persons is kind of a dirty word for for
Hegel when we have merely legal purse
this is a a low-grade forearm of spirit
and we might say all this is great
because you know other people can't mess
with me and prevent me from living my
life goals or charting out my own plan
or the pursuit of happiness if we want
to use Jefferson's and also you know to
a certain extent Locke's phrase as well
right
but for Hegel the loss of the the
meaning found within the community and
the necessary inequalities that would
come about with that is is a problem so
this is going to be a starting point for
us so he goes on and he says let's make
a contrast here what in the world of the
ethical order was called the hidden
divine law has emerged from its inward
state into actuality well that sounds
pretty good doesn't it so the divine law
is emerged into actuality but as we see
so often in the dialectic when something
emerges into actuality it often
transforms and turns out not to be what
we originally thought it was or what it
presented itself as being if we want to
talk phenomenologically he says in the
former state the individual was actual
encountered as such merely as a blood
relation of the family as a particular
individual Hegel tells us it was in
terms of his death and the rights that
were given or we might extend this a
little bit further it was in terms of
the recognition within the family that
the individual had the fullness of his
let alone her because we saw that you
know woman's place was largely confined
to the family and the divine law and the
dialectic of Hegel was given it to us so
far that that's where the locus of
meaning and recognition lay so here he
says he's emerged from his unreal
existence so that sounds like a progress
doesn't it because the ethical substance
is only the true spirit
he is that substance of the positive
universal but is actually a leti here
I'm skipping ahead a little bit because
the ethical substance is only the true
spirit the individual therefore
withdraws into the certainty of his own
self we see Hegel once again playing
with these two terms truth and certainty
they've become split from each other the
the universal has become you know true
but in the process has lost its
certainty where is certainty to be found
in the self consciousness the
consciousness for self of each
individual they can be certain of their
own status they can be certain of their
own desires but now it's unclear how
that fits into the universal community
so he says he is that substance as the
positive universal but his actuality
consists in being a negative universal
self why is Hegel talking about positive
and negative here well the positive part
is that the individual actually does
exist and make demands it's negative
insofar as each individual is in a
certain sense a restriction or a
negation in a particularly alien way of
the other individuals and of the
community by saying I have rights
I am placing limits on what you can do
or what the community can do not just in
terms of my body but in terms of my
property as well something that Hegel is
going to talk about a little bit later
so he says we saw the powers and shapes
of the ethical world swallowed up in the
simple necessity of a blank destiny this
power of the ethical world of the
substance reflected into simple unitary
nature right this destiny but now where
is the substance gone he says that being
which is reflected into itself the very
necessity of blankness destiny is
nothing else but the eye of
self-consciousness what an interesting
way to end this first paragraph isn't it
the the very necessity of blank destiny
what it was that the laws of the city
and the laws of the family or the divine
laws ultimately succumb to this whole
dynamic of individuals representing them
this destiny that swallowed them up
turns out to be not just some historical
contingency or to be nature inflicting
something but to be the pure eye of self
consciousness the pure eye that we've
seen coming up over and over and over
again how is this going to develop well
let's look at the next six paragraphs
and we'll find out
this therefore counts henceforth as a
being that is in and for itself to be so
acknowledged is its substantiality but
it is an abstract universality because
its content is this rigid unyielding
self not the self that is dissolved in
the substance
this very short
f-number 478 is in a certain way just an
addendum to the paragraph that came
before but it's also setting the tone
for what is to come
and notice that Hegel is going to employ
this language that he's been using
consistently throughout the
phenomenology it's something like a an
endpoint or a tell us that we're aiming
at being in itself being for itself
having these two together and he says
that the the eye of self-consciousness
that this destiny turned out to be the
eye of self-consciousness in each of the
individuals that we're talking about is
being in itself and for itself and so
you think okay we must be done here but
we're not actually we're just getting
started and he says to be so
acknowledged is it substantiality so
that's that's sounding good right we
want acknowledgement and we're seeking
ethical substance now notice what Hegel
says next it is an abstract universality
so abstract is okay but not good in the
Hegelian dialectic we're always trying
to aim for something that's not a mere
abstraction but something concrete
something real something that we can
relate to so an abstraction is just
going to be a beginning point why is it
that abstract individual universality at
this point he says because its content
is in this rigid unyielding self not in
the self that is dissolved in the
substance so let's think about this for
a moment what is he saying there good
because is the substance supposed to be
the community and the individual would
dissolve itself within that that's been
attempted so far and that never really
turned out to work or is the substance
in this case the individual person well
if it is then it doesn't make that much
sense for you know the universal that is
this to be dissolving itself in each
person so we must be looking for
something else
and what I'm going to suggest here there
was just going a little bit beyond the
text is that this is a drive for
something that won't be realized in this
section but will be realized later on
much later on in this whole discussion
and it's something that motivated the
previous speakings
both in the the reason section
particularly the last third of the
reason section and this is very
beginning part of spirit which is to
have what was being sketched out already
in the self consciousness section that
is a field in which human beings
recognize and are recognized within a
inorganic matrix which could be a
community or it could be something else
that is what we're aiming at that's
what's not anywhere close to being
attained at this point
personality that has stepped out of the
life of the ethical substance it is the
independence of consciousness and
independence which has actual validity
the non actual thought of it which came
from renouncing the actual world
appeared earlier as the stoical
self-consciousness just as it is
proceeded from lordship and bondage as
the immediate existence of
self-consciousness so personality has
proceeded from the immediate life of
spirit which is the universal dominating
will of all and equally their service of
obedience what was for stoicism only the
abstraction of an intrinsic reality is
now an actual world stoicism is nothing
else but the consciousness which reduces
to its abstract form the principle of
legal status an independent that lacks
the life of spirit by its flight from
the actual world it attained only to the
thought of independence it is absolutely
for itself in that it does not attach
its being to anything that exists but
claims to give up everything that exists
and places its existence solely in the
unity of pure thought in the same way
the right of a person is not tied to a
richer or more powerful existence of the
individual as such nor again to a
universal living spirit but rather to
the pure one of its abstract actuality
or to that one cross of consciousness in
general
here in paragraph 479 we're going to see
Hegel now discussing something that he
hasn't talked about for for quite some
time and that is stoicism now I want to
preface this by saying that we don't
want to get too bogged down in worrying
about whether Hegel adequately captured
stoicism and its potentialities whether
his take on it is totally fair or not I
mean quite frankly it's not it's a bit
reductive he does focus in on certain
aspects of it to the exclusion of others
in a way that that shows really that
that I don't think he fully understood
what the Stoics were up to but that was
very typical of his time particularly
for German scholarship you know of the
the 19th century what's really important
here is the connection that he's drawing
between what he's calling the stoical
self-consciousness remember that
stoicism was part of the self
consciousness section it wasn't being
treated as something just on its own you
know for its own sake and what is
developing now in this legal status
section in terms of spirit so Hegel
tells us personality it stepped out of
the life of the ethical substance it is
it is left the ethical substance behind
and it is a team to kind of
substantiality itself he says it is the
independence of consciousness and here I
actually put the German on the board
because I wanted to talk a little bit
about just you know what what the
implications of this are Miller has an
independence which has actual validity
which is not a bad translation
a little bit I would say it does
diverging from Hegel a little bit
Hegel has very cliche Galton de Dutch
standing kite right so independence is
zelf standing kite right being able to
stand on on one's own right
being able to to assert oneself in the
realm of being and vir CLE to Galton de
this is an interesting thing we might
say actually valid actually backing
itself up right there there's a Dyna
Missa tee here that I think is a little
bit lost in the English translation in
Independence which has actual validity
and independence which asserts its own
validity which makes that validity
actual so this is a quite important here
now notice where he's going after this
he says the non actual thought of it
which came from renouncing the actual
world appeared earlier as a different
shape of consciousness stoical self
consciousness he says look this
proceeded from lordship and bondage or
as we now more typically call it master
and slave as the immediate existence of
self consciousness he says so
personality is doing something similar
personality proceeded from the immediate
life of spirit which is a universal
dominating will of all and equally their
service of obedience so what are the
connections between the master-slave
dialectic and what was occurring in the
progressive uncovering of ethical
substance in the human and divine law
there was a complete devotion there was
a complete commitment on the part of the
slave it took place through the fear of
the master the being set to work
something similar occurred in the
interworking of human and divine law and
its representatives eventually realizing
that they could not bring that all the
way to term moving to a new shape of
consciousness you know the master-slave
dialectic is not the end of the
beginning of culture right stoicism is
something that emerges from it remember
stoicism was an advance beyond the
master-slave dialectic similarly Hegel
is casting legal personality as an
advance beyond the life of spirit
hitherto
so he goes on and he says here we go
what was for stoicism only an
abstraction of an intrinsic reality is
now an actual
world an actual world for consciousness
that's why I've got this question mark
over here we can say like Hegel does
look what was happening with stoicism
stoicism in his view renounced the
actual world it abstracts from the
actual world it retreats into something
that is very powerful the capacity for
human thought I would say that he is
right in in some respect to say that
stoicism does focus on the interior T of
the human person thinking about thinking
and thinking about our feelings thinking
about our thought processes not allowing
those things in the rest of the world to
dominate what's what's happening with us
and to see look you are only in
appearance to use Epictetus term right
or the famous phrase really out of the
enchiridion
I think Hegel is pretty much right about
that we're where he's wrong is is in
saying this is all stoicism is doing but
for him this is a you know sort of
reaction against reality
so he says stoicism is nothing else but
the consciousness which reduces to its
abstract form the principle of legal
status and independence that lacked the
life of spirit so the stoic attains
something but he also loses something in
the process and we saw that there was
for Hegel earlier on in the self
consciousness section sort of a
contradiction at the heart of stoicism
it was not able to adequately adequately
account for the development of its own
principles for how it is related to the
good the true the rational and why it
rejects the real is that going to be
happening here with personality he says
stoicism by its light from the actual
world attained only to the thought of
independence is personality going to
provide a kind of independence he says
stoicism is absolutely for itself in
that it does not attach its being to
anything that exists but claims to give
up everything that exists in places it's
asked and solely in the unity of pure
thought Hegel says then something really
interesting in the same way so there is
a parallelism to stoicism the right of a
person is not tied to richer or more
powerful existence of the individual as
such nor again to a universal living
spirit but to what to the pure one of
its abstract actuality or to that one
cross-sell consciousness in general
there is a not a withdrawal from reality
but you might say an evacuation of the
full meaning of reality there's
something missing here in in what Hegel
is calling personality missing because
it has been destroyed the meaning in the
dynamic community that was there earlier
that's no longer something available but
notice this other thing that he said
here the right of a person is not tied
to a richer or more powerful existence
of the individual as such a richer or
more powerful existence of the
individual as such what would be
supplying that that's what you want to
consider perhaps notions of something
like human perfection or virtue or the
development of human potentiality is
something that he's talking about there
and here's the thing with legal
personality you don't have to do any of
that sort of stuff you're great you're
golden just by yourself just by being a
person how sustainable is this going to
be I mean we know that it is sustainable
in a certain respect it does satisfy
certain needs
is this going to satisfy the human need
for something else to be connected with
ethical substance to be determinately
connected with other human beings
through recognition that's what we have
to ask and then answer through the
rest of this section
you